hello and welcome to this video playing
international master Providence let's
see some new missile probably this is
john bryant okay got a queen's gambit
you should have four yeah the night BDSM
line nowadays the main line in 94 that's
interesting system currently played and
by a couple of players most yeah well
I'm most popular into a well-known
player best known players kawana I have
never looked it looked at this line in
any in any way to be honest so I'm
probably knowing look less than my
opponent because I know nothing
yeah I'm just trying to play with them
simple means IAM easy and quick
development going to Castle next I
didn't do anything fancy against 94 I
know it's not refutable anyway as it has
been played yet a lot as mentioned on
the on the highest level so I'm content
with with a normal normal ish position
yeah black quite often goes with some f5
base setup let's see what he's doing
here that doesn't look super logical to
me to be honest now if you would play
some f 5 wait what he definitely has to
do is yes to think about white um maybe
capturing on b6 so this is something
that that he has to address maybe c6
is also easy to play hmm ok I cannot
play b5 nc6 as as some a3 is hanging
you
GP 6 bishops is seven hood at Sur is
rather complicated on b5 he will go back
to c8 and no you will not do that I
thought he absolutely had to I mean okay
maybe maybe this is not as bad as it
looks that's possible that he gets in
some f65 now him but he has to otherwise
is playing without without the bishop
wow wow
so I'm going here and how are you ever
moving the bishop from see aid f5 was a
WoW move because I was absolutely sure
he had to play some f 6 to retain the
option to play five the danger is if he
never moves his bishop then you'll also
never move the rook and is playing with
our two pieces
we'll see which I have strong strong
doubts about blacks pollution here this
is not ideal and that might even if I
lose an exchange or something if if I
maintain the bishop on CA and the rukon
AAA this is totally fine I was referring
to keeney to I mean I don't think that
the loss of the exchange for example is
this is much relevant yeah so if i take
the question is we dead you will take
with the sea pawn very very sure so that
rook a7 is actually possible yeah that's
that's pretty clear so how to how to do
that wonder if h4 is a move on my king
on f1 is not not ideal this is very much
clearer
hmm maybe this one asking him about his
next move
okay so h4 was one of my ideas like G
495 but maybe hey this is a wrong wrong
concept if I get an F for by the way
it's also pretty pretty strong maybe I
should just shoot for that prepare for
him okay that's it unless I'm blundering
stuff he's playing without the two
pieces now till the end of the game so
looking here and how to do that now I
think let's cover this
and we should be two coming for Bishop
h5 and I can take it form and now I can
take and see from here maybe age three
simply now that's a good book and open
up and gain the edge file so if it takes
there i can take with the f Paulette's
no no blurry so let's just pile up on
the edge file okay yeah just Queen d2
don't need any fancy stuff any more time
one cut this and now let's see rook will
come to f6 yeah I don't want to an open
up anything here for him and now
probably d5 should do the trick but
there is i can i can actually i can
activate even more here until everything
is as much active as possible rookie six
is that winning who probably is but d5
also also should should do the trick
hmm I shouldn't make a move Jeff lunch
at 40 but really quick at the end who
didn't really didn't really register my
my mind okay yeah he he allowed that
pawn to c6 this is in itself risky I
mean really risky but got to be honest I
think I think this is still probably
okay for him if he plays some f6 but but
after f5 I think this is unless you find
some some some technically um some
technical appointed way this is more or
less than losing move as he is never
moving the e porn anymore I mean as I
said maybe he can somehow yeah can find
some some tactic or something to to free
himself there but it's very difficult
the computer is on a simple plus one it
gives Jeep form and now with this line
now it is plus one black an energy force
hanging I'm sorry I guess to do
something like this first maybe here and
here's this what the engine is giving
and now it wants to take and go here
which at least activates the rook re
Dwight is better with the pawn here but
this is not as bad as the game next exam
probably something like that happened
this is still something that that
I can confide the way it the way it went
it was pretty awful you have to f4 not
know I I didn't see anything that you
can do now I just have to basically yeah
open up the position in some way without
blundering stuff and I could have
probably warned a lot quick of it you
can just activate to the maximum here
and then and play the decisive decisive
moves yeah it was funny yeah many moves
winded at all so this win I still have
the I have the a pawn this is the
problem he cannot stop the a pawn and
then end the deep on so it's it's a
pretty pretty clear win yeah it was a a
case of creating a dead piece with f5
and this is always really am forcing the
site who creates that that piece to be a
very cunning you have to somehow have a
concept how to bring this piece back
into the game it's not one piece
actually it also is the rook so the
bishop is out of play and it keeps the
rook out of play as well so it's a very
very difficult to manage position for
black okay well thanks for watching